okay so thanks sandy
like an introduction so you know as you
know like these are like really exciting
times in the field of information
technology right I mean we generally
don't know what comes next and so it's
it's really a pressure for me in fact an
absolute honor for me to come to
Stanford to this cauldron of innovation
and share with you some of the work that
I've been doing in the space of
commutation memory and get your opinion
on that I would also appreciate if the
if the if the lecture is going to be you
know very interactive so that I can see
questions during the during the talk
okay
so where do I come from I'm from IBM
Research in Zurich I just put up this
picture to show that it is actually a
very old research lab IBM research was
established does the zurich lab was
established in nineteen nineteen
fifty-six and you can see you know from
these pictures here you know luckily we
don't dress like that anymore in zurich
so currently the lab is located in this
beautiful village of freshly corn by the
but is auric lake and butt off late it's
looking more like that so all the more
reason for me to be in California now ok
so this is the agenda for the day so
first I want to you know talk about ok
what is this in-memory computing or what
is computational memory and why we need
it so it's a first part then I will look
at what is what constitutes its
computation memory now what do we have
in there then we'll talk about some of
the operations some of the computational
tasks that you can perform in in
computational memory and you know then
we will look at you know this concept of
mixed precision in memory computing and
finally I would conclude with a summary
and outlook ok so the motivation so I'm
sure that you guys have seen or what is
some of the statistics that is listed
here we have something like you know 2.5
exabytes of data created everyday right
and 90% of the data in the world today
has been creating the last two years and
the global scientific output doubles
every nine years so it's truly
remarkable the amount of data that that
we are generating on top of it we have
you know the the IOT revolution going on
right so if you look at some of the
estimates we will have something like
thirty billion devices connected to the
Internet by 2020 which is just a couple
of years from now right and it is all
the way from you know smartphones to you
know kitchen appliances and all these
things are generating all this
tremendous amount of data we are
expecting something like you know 40
trillion gigabytes of data to be
generated by all these devices which
would be on the internet so so the
impact of that is that an increasing
number of our computers are literally
combing through this vast amount of data
that is being generated and trying to
you know derive insights and
intelligence that's what they're doing
so much so that you know many of us
believe that we are on the cusp of you
know a revolution in artificial
intelligence so why is it important
because you know this AI revolution will
have significant impact on our computing
systems right and there's an immense
computation challenge involved there and
nothing tells the story better than
looking at the hood of one of those
computers which looks under you know
looks at the data and try to derive
intelligence and that is IBM's Watson
right a classic example which beat two
former world champions in 2011 in the
game of Jeopardy so it was a remarkable
achievement of course but the not so
remarkable aspect was at what cost so
Watson was consuming 80 kilowatts of
power as opposed to the human operands
consuming tens of watts
right Watson had 2880 processor trades
and 16 terabytes of RAM I'm pretty sure
the human opens in hell and much of this
you know inefficiency is attributed to
the fact that Watson you know just like
any other computing system that you're
working with is still based on the four
anointment architecture right that means
there's a physical separation between
where you store your data and where you
process that
and anytime you wanted to perform anyway
any time you want to perform computation
you have to move this data from the
memory to the processing unit and back
and forth so let's fast forward to 2018
right that's there 2018 that is yeah
this is the landscape of AI algorithms
over there I mean when you say a ideas
what it is right and in all these cases
all of them are running on conventional
fundament computers be it CPUs or GPUs
okay there are some Essex coming into
play but essentially they are all von
Neumann machines so what we have done is
that we have thrown in immense computing
resources into this problem of AI right
but even after that you know look at the
results we still need weeks to train
certain state-of-the-art deep neural
networks so in spite of having all these
computational resources in your hand
so before we say ok let us move and
beyond you know foreign women computing
of course there's a lot that we can do
in the context of foreign aemond
computing itself one of them is you know
this storage class memory the whole idea
there is as follows so if you look at
you know if you look soo-min to the
memory part of the you know the
architecture there we typically have a
fast volatile DRAM and a slow
non-volatile flash right so that's what
we have but now if we can have access to
a large amount of data which we can
store in a in a non-volatile fashion and
if we can access that reasonably fast
right then this will of course improve
the performance of this computing system
and that is what we typically refer to a
storage class memory so something which
sits in between DRAM and flash so
there's a lot of activity going on there
and and right now we have even started
seeing some commercial products coming
up which try to fill that niche area
right between des gram and flash then of
course there are ideas such as processor
in memory I think Andy was alluding to
that right so there's this idea of using
or bringing your processing units very
close to the memory system right
probably even in the memory chip so that
you can accelerate some workloads right
that's what he called processor in
memory or in
or in-memory computing or near memory
computing then of course there are more
exotic ideas like this one which is
being pursued here and Stanford actually
by Philip warm and so on where you have
this you know monolithic 3d integration
of memory interleaved with you know
computational layers right so this is
what you do so if you look at all these
approaches the overarching theme is to
minimize the time and distance to memory
axis right but they're all confined
within the four anointment architecture
so we are not deviating from the for
environment picture we are still in the
following world but we are trying to
minimize the time and distance to memory
access so what we do is fundamentally
different from it's a distinctly non fun
I mean approach and that is one we talk
about that is the in-memory computing
approach so again let us look at the the
conventional you know the system there
so you have your the processing unity at
the memory unit and you know you have
some data a written in the memory
somewhere right if you want to perform
the operation F of a on that memory a
memory a on the data a what you have to
do is you have to fetch that a bring it
all the way to the processing unit
perform there for free operation and
store it back into the into the memory
unit right and this is what is causing
this immense inefficiency now let's see
you know suppose we have another system
slightly different so you have a guinea
processing unit you have you know the
the memory here and besides the
conventional memory assume that they
have something called a computational
memory right sitting here and now this a
little BC written onto the computation
memory as opposed to the conventional
memory if you want to perform the F of a
operation right what you could possibly
do is you can apply a signal to the
computational memory unit to the a there
and somehow the F of a you know gets
done in in place in the memory itself
that's the whole idea right without ever
having to go into a processing unit so
this is the whole concept of in memory
computing
so there are a few caveats here of
course we cannot do all kind of stuff
right so we can perform certain
computational tasks using certain memory
cause in place without the need to
shuttle data back and forth in the
process but having said that we can do
quite a few things we can do logical
operations between varied medic
operations we can even perform some
optimization problems in this manner and
how exactly are we doing it we exploit
the physics of the storage devices right
so we exploit the physical attributes
and state dynamics of these memory
devices on which you store information
so that's all the idea here ok so before
I proceed are there any questions so far
or shall I go ahead ok perfect
so what do these you know I talked about
computational memory so what do they
comprise of right so let's look at you
know how we store information in our
existing memory devices right so if you
look at DRAM or flash in both cases you
store information in the charge state of
a capacitor right so in the case of DRAM
you have a capacitor which is in series
to a transistor if you have flash you
have a capacitor which is coupled to the
gate of a transistor so that the
presence or absence of charge is what
determines the logical state 0 and 1
right so clearly I mean this is the way
we have been storing information for
decades now and then I had invented the
diagram in 1966 right think about that
so that is how we have been storing
information there is some recent work on
using this type of storage devices to
also do in-memory computing but it's
very recent stuff but I still believe
that a better way to perform in memory
computing is using a different type of
devices and not the ones based on charge
based storage and that is what I want to
show here so in this mode of op in this
mode of storing information we don't
store information in terms of the charge
state of a capacitor but rather in terms
of the atomic arrangements within a nano
scale volume of material so you know if
you have one atomic arrangement you have
one logic state if you have another
atomic arrangement here another logic
state right
and these atomic arrangements you can
now alter by the application of
electrical pulses and you can measure
these differences in atomic arrangements
in terms of the resistance state by
measuring the low field resistance and
that we can decipher in which state you
are and in terms of the physical
mechanisms this spans a wide range of
mechanisms all the way from ionic drift
in metal oxides to phase transition in
certain types of materials so that is
the whole spectrum there so what I want
to talk about is you know you know in
more detail is one of these things which
is based on the phase transition and and
that is what what is known as the phase
change memory so phase change memory is
one such resistive memory device by the
way these you know this type of memory
is called resistive memory because you
are deciphering the stored information
which is in terms of the atomic
configurations by the resistance state
right that's why they are known as
resistive memory or memory stirs or
whatever phase change memory is one of
them so phase change memory is based on
this unique property of compounds of
germanium antimony and tellurium such
that in the disordered atomic
arrangement in the amorphous space they
have a very high resistivity and in the
ordered crystalline phase they have a
very low resistivity now if you take
this material and sandwiched them
between two metal electrodes as shown
here then by applying suitable
electrical pulses you can reversibly
change the face from the amorphous phase
to the coast line phase right and since
you have this big difference in the
resistivity values depending on the
phase configuration you can have you
know a very low resistance if it is
crystalline and a very high resistance
if it is amorphous and this of course
you can read back by applying a low
field a low bias voltage so that's what
you do so clearly in phase change memory
you can have these binary states which
is predominantly amorphous and
predominantly crystalline but we are a
also able to achieve intermediate phase
configurations you know by by again by
apply
suitable optical pulses so if you price
acrylic well since you are able to get
these intermediate you know or these
kind of mix face configurations which
means that we can achieve a continuum of
conductance values as shown here so
these are you know the the applied
voltage pulses I mean the amplitude of
the voltage pulse and this is the the
resistance value can see that you can
get this continuum right so essentially
what we have is an analog storage device
right because you can get this continuum
of states so besides the fact that we
can store this continuum of resistance
states in these devices these devices
also have some very rich dynamic
behavior so if you look at a PCM device
the the PCM dynamics is basically a you
know an implicit feedback
interconnection of electrical thermal
and structural dynamics so you know it
has a strong field and temperature
dependence there is a very interesting
thermal system there in a sense you know
there are huge gradients within the
within the device thermal gradients
which means that thermoelectric effects
will start playing a role but of course
what is also very interesting is that it
has very interesting structural dynamics
such as crystallization and structural
relaxation I will come back to it and
when I when I say how we can do
computation using the structural
dynamics right so that is why it's very
interesting so we should be able to
exploit the dynamics of PCM devices to
perform computation in place but first
let us look at you know performing
logical operations using computational
memory so I'll only have a couple of
slides on it but the reason why I want
to talk about logical operations is
because it is also one of the first you
know the initial ideas on computation
memory came about in the context of
performing logical operations so it's
good for the completeness sake so what's
the whole idea there if you look at the
conventional CMOS logic right there is
only one logic state that is represented
in terms of voltage right so your input
signals or voltage signals you process
on voltage signals and you output
voltage signal right in all cases you
have voltage signals and the CMOS gates
they essentially regenerate this state
variable during the computation process
that's what it does now suppose you have
these memories steep or assistive memory
devices into the mix right so why not
use the resistant state of these devices
as an additional state variable for
computation so that's the whole idea
here so if you take a resistive memory
device let's say in the high resistance
state it is in logic 0 and if it's the
low resting state it is in logic 1 and
the nice thing is that we can also
toggle them from one state to the other
by applying electrical pulses right so
which means that we should be able to
enable a whole bunch of logical
operations just by the interaction
between the voltage state variable and
the resistance state variable right and
in fact people of all the years have
come with many such logic families where
they created logic which comprised of
both these state variables as opposed to
just having voltage as a state variable
and why is it interesting because this
gives you a natural pathway towards
seamlessly integrating memory and
processing on they're on the same place
so I will just focus on just one such
logic family and that family has very
interesting property of statefulness so
what are you my statefulness so stateful
logic means that you only have one logic
state and this case is not voltage but
it's the resistance so that means you
only have resistance as the input and
output right so that's what you have so
I just illustrate that with one simple
example of how you could perform for
example the Noor operation in stateful
logic so let us say that I have these 3
devices which are hooked up in this
particular manner right and as I said
earlier in this logic family the logic
is represented only in terms of the
resistance state variable that means
sorry that means both the inputs are now
devices or in the resistance States so
these are the inputs and this is the
output now first let us initialize the
output resistance to say the logic state
1 which is the low resistance state
right now if either of these input
States is in logic 1 which means
logic it is in a Lauriston state and if
we apply a voltage signal VC here then
at least VC by 2 will drop across the
output state right and now now you can
tune your voltage in such a way that
when you do this operation the output
toggles from one to zero because of the
way in which you know the circuitous
hooked up now let's take the scenario
where both the inputs are in the zero
state that means they're in the high
resistance state if they are in the high
resting state and if I apply a VC here
hardly anything drops across the output
which means that the one remains as one
it doesn't normally yeah so so what
we've done is we have the the inputs
towards western states and the output is
also now you know is a result of the
logical operation nor in this case right
so what you've done is you're
implemented the the nor operation purely
using the resistance as the as a state
variable so that is the whole idea
behind stateful logic and so this is a
very simple thing so how can we scale it
up right so the idea is of course you
can now perform both bitwise operations
so you can have you can put the whole
idea into a large array where you don't
perform this operation at a single
device level but you cannot operate
across a whole row of devices so here
for example you have you know these this
draw of devices indicating you know this
vector here and there's an adjacent row
here and you would like to perform an or
operation and store it here so what you
do you first initialize all these
devices into the Lauriston state one and
now you apply this VC to the row and
what happens because of the way the
current flows clearly you will get the
nor operation implemented and written on
to the adjacent role here so we are able
to perform bulk bitwise operations in a
completely stateful manner and clearly
you know if you don't want to perform
this operation on some devices you can
of course use appropriate isolation
voltages to do kind of you know remove
them from the from the operation and
clearly the idea is that you know we can
now take more complicated processing
tasks you know breaking down into these
sub parts and then finally you can
you know work you work towards a more
general purpose processor based on these
very basic operations so that is the
idea behind performing logical
operations in in computational memory so
any questions yes devices right so
you're right I mean I mean this is very
simple in to show in this in the
PowerPoint sitting but in reality of
course you have to take care of the
switching dynamics and all these effects
so clearly you need to consider that not
really but I talked about the device
dynamics for example the electrical
dynamics so there are some very
interesting dynamics like called
threshold switching in phase change
memory so we have published a lot of
work on that but unfortunately today I
don't think I'll be talking about that
much but it's a very important yeah it
is in literature citations separate rows
of large memory device right yielding
years old yes inherently okay if this
word a useful function could it not have
been done with earlier technologies
going back decades with rams and so
forth my kind CMOS perhaps but the way
they memory works is to cause bit lines
to be pulled high if transistor is set
or cleared yeah not if it's not and with
an existing memory device pretty much
any technology if you deteriorate two
lines and either of them could pull the
bit line high you would have the same
function being performed all right in
fact that is a paper out of CMU and eth
where they show that you can do bulk
bitwise operations using DRAM I think I
have cited it in my references list
towards the end so maybe you could look
at it I think it I think they're doing
exactly what you are listing
ecology is that it allows to do this
whereas you don't need to jump to this
new somewhat less well established
technology liberties I'm missing the
linking technology with the philosophy
at the same time generally increases the
risk so sure sure and also mind you like
I just wanted to I'm not saying that
noise equal operation is the best thing
to do with these devices I mean I'll go
into other things as well right but on
but I must also say that even even in
this context there are so many other
logical operations that you can
implement there are many different logic
families right and some of them I'm sure
have their own merit I mean this
particular operation that you mentioned
I think there is some work very recent
work in fact where they were using DRAM
to perform this bulk retries operations
but also the fact that it is stateful is
very interesting that you I mean it's
non-volatile right which is which is
extremely nice so you never had read it
back at any point in time yeah I mean
it's not very clear I mean okay so I
will now move on to arithmetic
operations using computational memory
right so one of the arithmetic
operations that you can perform using
these devices is matrix vector
multiplication so suppose you want to
perform ax equal to B then what you
typically do is you arrange these
resistive memory devices in a crossbar
configuration C as shown here and then
you map the conductance values of these
devices proportional to the a values
here right so in g1 one is proportional
to a one and then you actually apply
voltage signals along the rows which is
now proportional to the X values here if
you do that then the the current that
flows through the column would be you
know proportional to the result be right
so what you've done is you're just using
the multi level storage capability in
this case
so now it's not enough that you only
have binary storage capability because
you need to map your a to G right so
that means you need this analog storage
capability and we are exploiting the
Kirchhoff's circuit laws the Ohm's law
and the and the kirchoff's current law
and what is really nice is that we can
actually you know reverse the process
apply the apply the voltage along the
columns and then and then read the the
current back through the rows and what
it does is now the multiplication with
the matrix transpose so this really nice
so you can perform multiplication with
the matrix and the matrix transpose at
the same time
okay so before we go about performing
this multiplication operations we should
be able to store the so we need to store
the conductance values in the devices
right and for that we use you know what
we call the ight rative programming
algorithm so that means we need to go to
a desired conductance value so for that
we apply a sequence of pulses so that
you can go to the desired value that you
want to program to so so I mean this is
an illustration of you know suppose you
want to go to a G target then you apply
some pulses then you look at how far
away you are from the G target and then
you keep on you know modifying the
applied pulse so that you can eventually
reach the G the G target value here in
fact this works beautifully well so
these are now experimental results from
our lab on on phase change devices
across a large array we are able to you
know go to a desired target value and
then these are the distributions that
show how well your algorithm is
performing right and then how you can go
to this
I'm go to these values here and once you
have this desired conductance value you
know achieved through this iterative
scheme then you can perform like scalar
multiplication so just this is just an
illustration of the Ohm's law again
experimental so what do you do you want
to perform beta is equal to alpha times
C you map your you know the Alpha value
to the conductance value programs the
device through the ight rative scheme go
there in a precise manner and then you
map your Reed voltage proportional to
the C value here and then you just read
back the current and that would be an
estimate of your beta correct we can
actually perform this operation over you
know in this case we have shown over a
thousand 24 combinations of alpha and C
that means many different devices
programmed to different conductance
values and so on and so forth and then
this is now the computed beta hat
against the exact beta you can see that
smallest linear right so it's fairly
good so this is the kind of precision we
have when you perform multiplication
using Ohm's law and this is the error
distribution you know again showing the
error distribution here and what we can
also do is we can always average and
multiple devices because these devices
are really tiny right so of course you
can have many devices to code the
information for you and then you can
take the average and as you can see as
you increase the number of devices on
your average then you are improving your
your multiplication precision right so
that is what you what do you do here so
against experimental data on on on PCM
devices now the question is suppose we
have a multiplier like that right using
these devices what is it good for in
fact there's a lot of work going on
right now where the people are using
this the crossbar based multipliers for
a range of applications so one specific
application that we looked at in zurich
is that of compressed sensing and
recovery so what do we do here
so in compress sensing the whole idea is
as follows so you take some signal from
a high dimensional space you you know
you you you compress it into something
to allow the lower dimension
then thereafter you reconstruct that
signal in an accurate manner right and
what is really nice is that we perform
this sampling and compression in
simultaneously that means unlike other
compression schemes we are not taking
the whole signal and then we are
compressing but rather as in when we
sample the signal we are compressing it
right that's the whole idea as you can
imagine this compress sensing is
extremely useful in several applications
such as MRI or facial recognition you
know or even mobile phone camera senses
and so on writes extremely useful in
many domains so how do we do it it's an
extremely simple operation so if you
look at compression we are taking a
signal from say dimension n you want to
bring you to dimension m and if the
compression is done using a linear map
then of course you can do it with a
simple multiplication in a matrix right
so Y is equal to ax so this is n
dimensional input M dimensional output
now this a matrix can be coded into the
memory steve array correct so with the
order one time complexity you can
perform the compression is the easy part
single multiplication now the
reconstruction is a bit more tricky
there you need to convert this m
dimensional signal to an n dimensional
signal right and there typically you go
to some i traited procedure and one such
eye trait of reconstruction is based on
this approximate message passing
algorithm that it came out of plus
imaginary here in Stanford so where you
you you have this iterative scheme
whereby you reconstruct your higher
dimensional signal from the lower
dimensional signal that you compress to
right and if you look at this algorithm
what you see is that it has a whole
bunch of matrix vector multiplications
involving the a matrix as well as a
transpose and both of them we can use
the same array for that right so that
means we have a single measurement
matrix which is n by M dimensional
rather right M by M by n dimensional
matrix and we use the same array to
perform the the compression as well as
reconstruction
that's the beauty of the whole thing and
if you work out the math you see that in
this way overall for the reconstruction
we can reduce the complexity from order
n em to order n so that's a significant
reduction in the in the complexity so
does it work yes it does
so we performed experiments on this
image compression I mean this is
actually compressed sensing in the
context of image compression where we
took this image which is 128 by 128
pixel image then we do a 50% you know
compression on that image and then we
reconstructed it while all the time we
had coded the information the
measurement matrix onto a PCM array so
we have a measurement matrix do the
entirely code in the PCM array all the
multiplications are done using Ohm's law
and then we have gotten back the result
from that a couple of very interesting
points here so one thing first of all
the reconstruction is not too bad
right I mean given that we had such low
precision right and by the way I have
also shown here the normalized mean
square error as a function of the
iterations I told you the reconstruction
is a nitrate a process and if you look
at the the normalized mean square error
a couple of things one thing is of
course it is not as good as floating
point but very interestingly the the
convergence rate is not affected by that
it is good right because your height
relative algorithm it's still converging
with the same speed even though it is
done with lower precision multiplication
if you look at it it is a slightly
better than a 4 by 4 fixed point
implementation so which means that our
multiplier is having you know an
equivalent precision of a four bit four
by four bit fixed point operation and if
you have to do the whole thing now you
know implement in FPGA or something we
still have a power reduction of
something like 50 times so that's what
you gain and also mind you when you look
at the measurement matrix just a
dimension of n by M right so it's a lot
of data and all this data is now
residing in the computational memory
ever having to come back to the
processing unit right so that's a big
advantage here so that's that's a lot of
data that you can store in the
combination
and perform these operations on them
okay so any questions on this part huh
yes so it takes like some like six to
seven write operations yeah oh if each
operation so that the PCM the the right
pulse is I mean it
typically it's learnt from like 50
nanoseconds 5-0 so is unit like six of
them took it together right yes yes it
depends on how many right heads we have
right so typically the limit comes from
you know how much current can flow
through the through the wires right
essentially but having said that in all
these applications you are not changing
the weights at all right I mean if you
look at the the compress sensing it's
always the measurement matrix sitting
there right it's never changed once
you're programmed so then it's being
used for all kind of compression stuff
right so it's kind of like a thing that
you can amortize I think so you just
look at the cost of writing yes
five volts or five in with this yeah
but having said that I view
computational memory as an extension of
memory right so you have you have memory
and you have typically of memory
controllers right so even now if you
have a memory chip right you have your
you know you have your memory controller
which is taking care of some of these
these things right so we'll have a
computational memory controller which
will do these conversions that is
required because because if you look at
you know if you have a multi-level you
know flash chip right I mean it does so
much stuff right even even now it does
titrated programming for example right
so many of the things that I mentioned
here are already being done in existing
memory chips so III cannot see of
anything which is substantially
different from what is already not there
okay so let's now go to computing with
device dynamics so you know I talked
about logical operations at medic
operations so the question is okay can
we do a bit more right can we use can be
computed using the dynamics as you know
for the logical operations we're just
using the binary storage capability for
arithmetic operations we use the
multi-level storage capability but
either of them didn't use any dynamics
right so this is a vision here so we
have a whole bunch of memory devices
sitting there right you want to perform
F of a operation on those devices so
what you do is you apply an electrical
signal to this to all these devices
right and the idea is that the
conductance of these devices now evolves
in accordance with this electrical input
and somehow the result of the
computation gets imprinted on the memory
devices right that's the whole idea
that'll be really cool so one obvious
candidate at least in the context of
phase change memory for performing
computation is the so-called
crystallization dynamics
so what we see is that if you have a PCM
device and if you now initialize sitting
to a predominately amorphous state as
shown here then if we apply electrical
pulses such as these you know you know
if you if you successively apply them
what you see is that the the crystal
front will grow right as shown here that
means you will progressively break a
slice and which means that your
conductance of the device will keep on
increasing as shown here so if you apply
the number of pulses as shown here as a
number of pulses increases your
conductance key keeps increasing here
correct and what's also nice is that if
you increase the amplitude of the
programming pulse then you have a larger
increase in your conductance as shown
here so so this is now increasing
current you see 50 all the way 300
micrograms and these are the this 100
micron cohere so can we use this very
interesting behavior for computation so
essentially what we have is is a
non-volatile integrator right an
accumulator so can we use it for
performing computations so first I will
take as a first tech application I will
show how we could use it probably to
find factors of numbers it's it's more
like a toy example but I think it really
gives an idea of how the whole thing
works so let's take a PCM device assume
that it is initialized in such a way
that you know it goes into a low
resistance state after you apply X
number of pulses right because then
that's when it it completely could
slices right it just goes into this
state here the question is can we use
this device to perform different to find
if X is a factor of Y so what do you do
you know you have a you have a larger
number Y sitting there and you want to
know if X is a factor of Y right you
apply Y number of pulses to the device
and and as you apply the pulses at any
point in time if the resistance of the
device goes to Lauriston state then you
reset it back correct and then you keep
on doing it till you finish applying Y
number of pulses and after the
application of the Y number of pulses
then you just go back and measure the
resistance of the device if it is in the
isten state the Nexus effect of why
otherwise not right it's a very simple
very simple algorithm so this is just a
schematic illustration again so you want
to know if 4 is a factor of 8 you apply
8 number of pulses you know these are
the eight pulses here after the
application of the eight pulses you
measure the resistance oh yeah the
device from the low resistance state yes
for its effective weight right is for a
factor of ten you apply ten pulses you
measure the resistance after the
application of ten pulses residence is
high no it's not effective correct so
that is as simple as that
does it work experimentally yes it does
but also even better we can do it in
parallel that means I can have say you
know different devices initialized to
different states so for example this
device corresponds to thirteen eleven
nine six and four so this is a number of
pulses it takes for it to go to the
Holston State and then you apply Y
number of pulses to all of them right
and then you go and check okay how many
of those devices are right now in the
Lauriston state and okay those are the
ones which are factors of Y right that's
the whole idea here this is an
experimental illustration now in this
case so you have again you know the I
mean the same same concept here number
of pulses here at any point in time you
could just go and check you know how
many devices are the loads in state and
you can figure out which those factors
it's an example you look at 44 here
right you will see that the device which
corresponds to X equal to 4 and X equal
to 11 both of them are in the Lauriston
state at 44 that means 4 and 11 are
factors of 44 right it's a very simple
experiment you know which shows you know
what I mean by computing in place and
storing the data in the device in the
form of the resistance levels but
clearly I mean it is more or less a toy
example just to illustrate the concept
here let's now move on and see if we can
solve more interesting problems right
and one such problem is learning the
correlations between signals in a
completely unsupervised manner it's a
very interesting problem it arises in a
range of applications so suppose you
have a whole bunch of you know even wave
data streams by the
stochastic processes coming into a
correlation detector a subset of these
processes are weakly correlated you
would like to find out which ones they
are
right so you can imagine it comes up in
you know a lot of applications where you
probably want to find out anomaly or you
want to know which signal is interesting
and so on right it comes in that context
the question is can we perform this
using this operation using the device
dynamics indeed yes so what do you do
you take these even based processes so
they are binary stochastic processes
that means the ones and zeros right so
you have n processes maybe a million of
them right they are all coming into the
in they're coming into the PCM array the
the computational memory each of the
process is now assigned to a single PCM
device as shown here and anytime there
is a one here you apply a pulse to the
Pythian device right parts right one of
these crystalizing pulses and the
amplitude of the pulse is now
proportional to the instantaneous some
of the processes so this one here right
at any point in time you count okay how
many of them are there and the amplitude
is not proportional to that I must also
say that okay before we start the whole
thing we have to initialize all the
devices to a high resting stage fully
amorphous state right and what you see
is that as this progresses over time all
those devices which are now connected to
the correlated processes they go towards
a high conductance state and the ones
which are connected to the uncorrelated
processes they remain at the low
conductance state so now just by reading
back the resistance values of these PCM
devices we are able to determine which
prophecies are temporally correlated and
which ones are not right in fact it is I
mean this looks very trivial this
algorithm but what it does is that it is
finding out the sum of the covariance
matrix of these of this data here so
it's what it does yeah so that that's
what it does right it is MIT is very
simple looking I'll
here and this is also one instance where
you really are performing here rather
soft stickier computational tasks
completely in memory and then the result
of the computation is being stored in
the memory itself
so again does it work yes it does so we
have you know a million devices in this
case these are all experimental results
again each of the PCM devices is now
connected to one of these stochastic
processes in this case you know these
are represented by these flickering
pixels here so each time the the pixel
is flickering that is is one of these
ones showing up right so that's that's
the process here and some of these
pixels are flickering with a weak
correlation it's very difficult to
figure out because it's 0.01 is it is
the correlation coefficient right you
cannot really see it but now these each
of these pixels is now mapped to a
million devices arranged here so it's
thousand by thousand devices and now you
can see the conductance values as read
from the PCM device you see it's
evolving time progresses and you see
that okay these were the pixels which
were temporally correlated and that
information is now completely returned
into the PCM device so you can imagine
this is one instance where we really
cannot say we're processing is happening
in where storage is happening right if
someone can tell me okay where is the
processing and so it would be extremely
interesting to see that and so what we
have is we have now imprinted the result
of the computation into the memory
devices yeah so so that's that's that's
that's the idea here so we wanted to see
okay how these kind of algorithms fare
against state-of-the-art computing
systems right someone could say okay I
can implement this algorithm in a
state-of-the-art computing system so for
that we chose this particular system
with two power eight processes and and
and four GPUs you know here and we try
to implement the exact same algorithm
that that that was used for the you know
what I what I talked about earlier
implemented in this system here right
and it was also implemented with a lot
of optimization to make sure that we use
all the parallelism and all that stuff
and so this is now the run time as a
function of the number of processes view
and you can see that by the time we
reach like 10 million processes even in
run time our system is a factor of 200
better than the implementation on the
conventional computing systems right so
that's the power of the system and of
course in terms of energy we are far
superior again orders of magnitude
better in terms of the power so so to my
knowledge is one of the largest and most
significant demonstrations of really in
memory computing is in device dynamics
where the result of the computation is
written into the into the devices will
be surprised but in this case we just
want to compare you know apples to
apples right your PCs I'll be interested
knowing which one which algorithm that
is though because two algorithm that we
tried one of them is the k-means which
of course is not more efficient than
this the other one is the one where with
some of the covariance matrices right
GPUs know these are the two we looked
into and so one of them is but if you
have something else I'd be interested
yeah a decision to deliberately choose
the exact same algorithm yeah idea was
mostly to try you know if did to make a
fair comparison between the two huh you
may not be taking advantages of
properties of the GPUs so it's an unfair
comparison to say well look how much
power we say but look how much faster we
are when perhaps a different algorithm
would have made that difference less but
do you have in mind or it doesn't matter
whether I have it okay because we
couldn't think of anything else I mean
you know when you go for when you try to
find correlations between those those
patterns I mean the two things that came
to mind or were these two algorithms
right right so I don't know there's
something else that we could try but
yeah but yeah it's interesting
any other questions on this party
[Music]
information if you speak about billions
elements yes you mean to say we're very
put up trash old and so on right yeah
yeah yes yes I guess you I mean it's
it's I mean you should know you know how
many processes you have and what is the
you know what is the rate of the process
and how much correlation we expect so
there are some rough you know
calculations you could do to figure out
how to set the set the thresholds right
it's basically putting a threshold on
the binary classifier right so you can
get some idea on you know on what it
should look like but you are right it it
requires some tuning of course
it looks to me like right now the
problem would be working get from and
Mister devices it looks like you have to
make the furlough level device to
actually take advantage of this isn't
that correct yeah you mean to say right
I can't go by supplier this is this is a
situation where you're building
something with the very specific intent
and tailoring it to a particular class
of problem that's it yep and but having
said that I think if you look at all the
memory manufacturers out there I mean
they're all capable of doing it like
Samsung isn't all that weird so but
whether it is easily accessible in any
academic environment that's a different
question but I think many of the
companies they have access to what he
said yes so you actually can get
advantage by creating a special purpose
machines neither terribly chic right ok
so let's move on to the next topic which
is you know essentially makes precision
computing so I guess the elephant in the
room so far is you know the lack of
precision right I think that's one thing
which people keep saying I mean again
came up in the context of calibration
but also you know I showed you earlier
how we perform matrix multiplications
and again you see that there is a lot of
precision issues there so that is why we
start looking into this concept of mixed
precision computing to counter that so
that's what I'm gonna talk about so so
what is the challenge of imprecision so
let's assume that you know you know you
know when you compute these memory
devices we often we don't go to the
exact solution that you want to write
but that's okay in machine learning
because there are lot of problems where
you're okay you can tolerate a whole
bunch of
imprecision because there's no real
golden answer when it comes to comes to
some of the machine learning problems so
it pretty much like this you know this
drunken guy who wants to go to his
destination here but he ends up with an
approximate solution and he's happy
about it right so that's that's that's
one class of problems but of course
someone could say ok no he has to go to
the precise solution right what if we
need arbitrary high precision what do we
do so what you can do is you can give
him a GPS every accurate one which now
at any point in time tells him ok how
far you are away from the exact solution
so if he has this GPS in his hand then
he can afford to make some imprecise
steps right approximate steps but he can
keep recalibrating himself and
eventually reach the the final solution
so this is the whole idea or this is
what leads to you know the concept of
mixed position computing or in the
within the context of computing itself
you will see that many computational
tasks can be formulated as a sequence of
low and high position components so what
you can do is when you want solve the
computational task you can have you can
split the two things one of them in the
first step you have an approximate
solution is obtained right and that one
typically takes higher computational
load and the resulting error in the
overall objective is calculated in a
precise manner inaccurately right so
that's the second step then you keep
iterating over it right and in that case
you can reach your very high precision
very high accurate solution in the end
so that leads us to mixed precision in
memory computing so what do you do here
so you always use your low precision
computational memory in conjunction with
a high precision standard foreign
language machine right and then we use
you know the bulk of the computation you
still try to perform it on the
computational memory unit but then you
do the error correction or error while
finding out the error operation that you
perform in this precise foreign I mean
machine so what you can see is that if
you do it in the right way in many
problems you can still gain
lot of area land power speed efficiency
even though we have this for anointment
a machine in conjunction used in
conjunction with the computation of
memory unit so this is a very powerful
concept and it's a very good solution
towards you know dealing with the lack
of precision associated with
computational memory so I'll show you a
couple of examples to prove it to you so
one of them is the problem of solving
systems of linear equations right so if
you want to solve this problem if ax
equal to B find X then one way to go
about it is you first find an initial
solution X right and then you start
making approximate additions to it so
these are the corrections to it so X
equal to X plus Z and how you find your
Z is by solving yet and the problem is
equal to R but this time in an
approximate way we use typically Kyllo
subspace methods such as conjugate
gradient descent or GM race or one of
these approaches and the catch is that
the R here which is a residual has to be
calculated with very high precision
right so that's a catch if you look at
this in a solver there are a whole bunch
of matrix vector multiplications
involved all that stuff you offload to
the computation memory right because in
this computation memory unit we are
storing the a matrix right which we are
using over and over again so we are not
reprogramming it right so we only had to
program it when you have to solve that
that ax equal to B problem if the right
hand side changes doesn't matter right
if B changes it doesn't matter you can
still use the same thing but for the
whole thing you perform all the
multiplications in here and and finally
of course the algorithm runs till your
residual is below a tolerance which you
set right so that is how how you solve
the problem so now these are now again
experimental results on the on the PCM
devices so this time we perform this
experiments on the so-called model
covariance matrices so these are a
special type of matrices which have this
you know this decaying behavior as shown
here they are kind of simulating the you
know the decreasing correlations
you know between features as you move
away from the diagonals right so that is
what it's kind of capturing there they
occur very often in data analytics
related problems and all the matrix
multiplications are performed using PCM
devices again fabricating the 19 animal
technology node and this is now the norm
of the error between the exact solution
and the and you know estimated solution
plotted against the number of iterations
again it's an iterative scheme and you
can see that for all these matrix
dimensions the error keeps dropping
right and it's not limited by the
precision of the computational memory
unit it is only limited by the precision
of the high precision you know in fact
we did one experiment all the way till
it reaches the Machine precision of the
foreign lineman machine right because
it's not limited by that that's a
property of the algorithm so this way we
can beat this problem of you know the
lack of precision involved in the in the
multiplication and still get a very
accurate solution so this is the this is
one example so and and then I don't have
to convince you that you know there's a
very useful thing to do and it's solving
systems of linear equations but of
course this appears a lot in in problems
associated with data analytics so one
such problem is you know the task of
finding the gene interaction networks
from RNA expression measurements for
cancer and normal tissues so what you do
is you you you get the covariance matrix
you find the inverse covariance matrix
and finding inverse covariance matrix
involves solving a whole bunch of linear
equations and all this stuff is done in
a PCM device so the covariance matrix we
programmed it into the PCM array and
then we solved all these linear
equations the different right hand side
and then we obtained these gene
interaction networks from the
experiments right and then of course you
can see that while some of the gene
interactions are preserved there is a
big difference between the connectivity
graphs between those linked to cancer
cells and and normal cells normal
tissues so just realist raishin of you
know how you could use these kind of
things in in a problem like data
analytics but the natural question is
okay what do we gain by going through
all this process right by mixing the
four norm and machine with with with the
computational
in fact we did a lot of studies system
level measurements in fact where we used
power eight CPUs and and p100 the Pascal
100 GPUs as the high-precision units and
along with the computational memory and
what you see is that we have significant
improvements in the time energy to
solution as you go to larger matrices as
opposed to doing the full CPU only OGP
only implementation right so we can gain
a lot if we use Cisco if you had access
to this computational memory in addition
to just having the processing units and
what is also very nice is that if at all
the in-memory computing becomes more
accurate then your gain performance
becomes more right that's really nice
because your convergence becomes faster
so the hope is that as and when the
memory devices mature and we start
getting better devices then we can tap
into this property that means things get
better right this as it goes along ok
another application of mixed precision
computing is that of training deep
neural networks so as you know you know
I mean deep neural networks they are
essentially you know loosely inspired by
the brain so you have this multiple
layers of you know parallel processing
units which we called neurons and they
are interconnected by this plastic
synapses and once you've tuned the
synapses in a very nice manner then
these networks are able to solve certain
tasks remarkably well in fact some of
the state-of-the-art neural networks can
they even outperform humans right in
terms of tasks such as image recognition
and and voice recognition so that is
really really interesting but how are
they trained so these networks are
trained based on a global supervised
learning algorithm as you know it is
back propagation so the whole idea is
you know you take your inputs you
propagate through through these neuronal
layers it's a forward propagation step
right and where the synaptic network
will now perform much multiply
accumulated operations the final layer
responses are compared to the input
labels the resulting error is calculated
and they are now back propagated again
matrix vector multiplications multiply
accumulate opera
at each layer you will have its own
error and you will now change your
synaptic weights in such a way that you
reduce you error right so it has a
forward propagation backward propagation
and synaptic weight update three steps
so that is the whole idea behind forward
propagation and behind back propagation
what we do is essentially brute force
optimization right we have millions of
synapses and we keep doing this over and
over again over multiplied samples
multiplied box and finally everything
gets strained if you look at now you
know the state-of-the-art networks it
takes days and weeks to Train even on
highly sophisticated cpu GPU clusters
right so that is the status now and a
big reason for this inefficiency is
again because you're storing your
synaptic weights you know in one place
and every time you need to perform
computation you need to bring it perform
computation storing back right so that
is that's one big reason for the
inefficiency so can we do better right
so this is one idea where we can apply
this mixed precision approach to deep
learning so let's say that you know we
we take a neural network layer and then
we map your synaptic weights again into
a computational memory as shown here you
perform the forward propagation with
order one time complexity using these
synaptic layer here perform backward
propagation by opening that that inverse
transpose operation so that again you
use the same away but the weight update
however has to be calculated in high
precision correct and that you perform
in your high precision limit and anytime
you're updated weight exceeds some value
you issue some programming pulses to the
devices in a completely blind manner so
you you just apply this you know you
nudge them forward or backward right it
and what you see is that this system is
able to learn in to train so I will I
will show you an example of that how it
works so we basically took like an M
NIST handwritten digit classification
problem again you know these are the
input neurons and these are the outputs
of course telling you which digit it is
and then we used now PCM devices the
synaptic weights
and and as you see here this is now the
training accuracy as a number of the
epic numbers here and after the training
process what you see is that the the
network is able to achieve ninety seven
point seven eight percent accuracy which
is quite respectable right and so this
is really interesting so we are able to
perform all the forward and the backward
propagation in place using the memory
state devices but and only accumulating
the the weights in high precision right
again it's a classic mix position in
memory computing approach which leads
you to this very nice performance okay
so that brings to the summary of my talk
so first of all I mean as I said because
of this explosive growth of data centric
AI applications we have this immense
computing challenge that we need to deal
with and the computational memory I
believe is a significant step towards
that it's essentially a memory unit that
can perform certain computational tasks
in place and it comprises typically of
what we call resistive memory devices
where you store information in terms of
the resistance state of devices and of
course in computational memory in some
types of combinational memory you can
perform logical operations in place and
then of course you can do arithmetic
operations and one such very interesting
primitive that we can do there is matrix
vector multiplications that we can
perform in order one time complexity and
of course you have a wide range of
replications one of them being the
compressed sensing and recovery that I
talked about another very fascinating
aspect is computing the device dynamics
I think a lot can be done in that space
I just showed a couple of examples where
I used the accumulative dynamics of
devices to perform computation in place
one of them being finding temporal
correlations in an unsupervised fashion
and clearly I think mixed position in
memory computing is a significant step
rewards tackling this key problem of
imprecision that arises in computational
memory alright and there I think there
are why
range of applications I just stretched
upon two very important ones one of them
is solving systems of linear equations
the other one being training do deep
neural networks so I just conclude with
just an outlook of how I see the
computing systems are evolving over the
next couple of years it's a very
difficult task but I think I still stick
up my hand and say something about it so
first of all you know you have your
conventional computing system so what
you see is that you know I strongly
think that storage class memory has a
place sorry it has a place you know
going forward I think it will become
more and more prominent a lot more place
we'll get into that seeing that there's
a market there and that will of course
improve our computing systems for the
good and I think there'll be a lot more
research going on in your memory
computing I think I think it'll get more
traction now with all the requirements
in in in air related research of course
for Norman accelerators I mean GPUs
general-purpose GPUs are all over
Romania so if it is right now but I
think there'll be a big push towards
Essex which are more tailor-made for
specific applications like deep learning
and so on so this you would see in the
near future so that's about it for the
foreign women side of things but in the
non-fun mind side I think that
computational memory could start playing
a role it was heavily depend on how
successful storage class memory is going
to be right because then they could feed
each other right because the essential
element is the same in both of them
right so so this is something that that
could be very interesting going forward
but even further down the road I
strongly believe that we will start
seeing more more of neuromorphic o
processors because you know essentially
our brain is a remarkable engine of
cognition it is for us the existence
proof that we can perform you know
learning with remarkable energy
efficiency so clearly I mean that is
probably where we will all go at some
point but probably a few years years
down the road I must also say that there
is a nice confluence now of you know
work in computational neuroscience and
nano scale devices which could all come
together to make you know make this
possible this whole neuromorphic
coprocessors and of course there is
you know quantum computing clearly
lurking in the background which we don't
know how that would play out right so
that to me is like my outlook or my take
on on how things are proceeding this
space I would like to thank my my
students my colleagues my collaborators
and also some very generous funding from
the European Union as well as the Swiss
National Science Foundation thank you I
mean the right times are mostly governed
by the how fast the material
crystallizes so it's not really the size
of the device that that place they're
all there so the size of the device is
mostly influencing the reset current
right how much current you need for
programming but in terms of the speed it
doesn't play that bigger role so if if
speed is a concern there are materials
phase change materials which could slice
much faster or even one nanosecond if
you want I mean there are like I mean if
you take like pure GTE germanium
telluride it it could slice is much
faster than the ones we used here but
there are there are reasons why we use
this material as opposed to that because
this brings something else writes a
trade-off in the end right what is that
what does it bring one thing one reason
why we use this material is because it
has a lower current of operation you
know you need less current to operate it
because you have bloody devices now
right so that's a big concern for us so
we want to reduce the current with which
we can operate it but if you say okay if
you are going to smaller dimensions then
your current is anyway lower then you
you could probably go to the faster one
you see so it's it's a multi-dimensional
optimization problem in the hint
I have two sets of questions I'll save
one basically a hardware question of
software question let me ask the
hardwood question yes I was expecting to
say a little more about the memory
architecture because other firms such as
first when I heard Anil for in Aurora
Colorado the second was came out of that
was Tara up in Seattle which bought
craning and what they did with their
memory in addition to parity with the
correction of the detection was they
dumped lamented full empty bits and they
did semaphore memory that said anything
about how you would feel with race
conditions between processors to your
memory here I'm assuming your smallest
regular memory but you know the database
community Jim Gray convinced the people
who say well we have this concept acid
atomic consistent yeah I mean okay first
of all I mean I mean we are doing we are
using like you know the memory like so
this is all done before the memory
controller right there's really done in
the analog space right so we have read
and write heads integrated in the memory
chip but we are working with real analog
values so so the I didn't talk anything
about the memory controller because all
that stuff is right now when an FPGA in
that picture that I showed earlier right
so we have just a pure analog memory
chip and then we have this FPGA wrapped
around it which does all the other stuff
so it's it's quite far from you know
working with a real memory chip right it
is still an emulation of how a
computational memory looks like that's
why I couldn't touch upon that much okay
I might be getting hung up in details I
was intrigued by your example of how to
use these technologies to factor 100 if
4 is a factor of 10 you hit the system
with ten pulses Inspectorate four yes
that doesn't seem to scale to whether
inspectors at 10 to the 13th - 7 I that
was mostly intended as a toy example to
show how you could do some combinations
don't assert in the memory right my
sense is that you're sort of suggesting
a combination of digital and analog
techniques yes and the analog techniques
are so I must also say that some of the
things I talked about like the matrix
vector multiply is right like the ones
which I showed here these ones I think
are you know this is something that we
can use right now right I mean as I said
if you have a mixed precision
architecture and if you have this rather
imprecise multiplier but if it can do a
lot of multiplications in order one time
complexity then this is something that
you can incorporate new computing system
right so it's not completely exotic at
this point so this precision is
equivalent to something like 4 to 6 bit
fixed point right and again you don't
have to really beauty as an analog
system because you have a digital
interface there right so you have Dax
lady sees and you have the memory which
is sitting there of course it's a bit
imprecise but that's what it is right
you can take into a digital system and
you can incorporate it so this one is
not so exotic but some of the things
that I said with the computing the
device dynamics is more exotic and there
we need to more research it's not ready
for prime time yet but I just want to
show that we can use these these kind of
properties to potentially perform
computation in place and that's why I
showed these two examples they're a true
biological neural network does not
encode a whole opposition
and you see it already with the neural
network example right so if you have you
know I mean if you if you have if you
store the synaptic weights in this
precision and you enforce it
during the training process then that
seems to be enough right
so so that's that's a very interesting
thing and and and i think i think mixed
precision is also very good idea in a
sense that really you know allows us to
get this orbital high precision with
these you know faulty devices right
which is which is extremely useful at
least in the beginning application or we
have to have specialized right at the
beginning before I manufacture them I
can use for anything
yep here when you build it looks like a
the UNAM innocence that i can program it
to do multiplication do neural networks
yes capability to program different
aspects of these things and tie them all
together right you could have like
multiple cores in a single chip right
because I mean this is nothing right
having 1 million 1 megabyte is one but
one mega cell is not a not a big deal at
all right so you can have many different
codes that's one option you could have
you know one core yeah in program yeah
exactly
so yeah
yeah Jimmy as I said earlier Jimmy I
view combinational memory is an
extension of memory supposed to a
processor right so it's really you're
trying to it should look very similar to
a memory chip in some sense that would
be the ideal scenario I was wondering if
there are any other types of fields of
arithmetic computations that land itself
really well for this like in this do
really fast is that be I mean I'm gonna
get this from like a they'll be really
interesting in in in cryptography if
this can do incredibly fast discrete
logarithms that can be potentially
problematic I think that could be
because as I said I mean if you look at
now the the electrical characteristics
of these devices right so they have this
nice exponential field dependence right
so maybe someone could exploit some of
those things right so I mean it's it's
yeah it's to early days I think but I
think it's possible to have more
complicated functionality out of these
devices we still I mean make a lot of
stuff together with Global Foundries
right so that was the come again yeah so
we design it and then yeah I mean but
it's not just a PCM chip we have a lot
of I mean the PCM was not done in Global
Foundries because we still have in a
fabrication facilities within IBM where
we can do PCM but the circuit the CMOS
was done elsewhere
and he attempted two different languages
so let's question is what's offer our
audience here yeah thank you if you went
out for instance of the higher force
computing world the first thing they're
gonna ask was Danny Hillis had to come
back tail tail between his legs and
apologizing says yes for the connection
machine we finally got around and
developed a Fortran compiler no clearly
there is a lot of work to be done in the
software stack side but having said that
you know general-purpose accelerators
sorry special-purpose accelerators like
you know I mean I mean like PLAs seeing
some of the GPUs right I mean and all
the infrastructure around it was built
up right so I don't see anything
substantially more different there in
this case as well so but it's an
interesting African effort really to
look at the like the problems you have
to figure out how to you know break it
down into two parts which can be done in
the computational memory are supposed to
elsewhere but it's also Sonia we are
looking into but I don't have ya know
obvious thing is a matrix vector
multiply oh right I mean this would be a
very very efficient thing to realize
right so I would say that would be the
first met
that's sort of one small question
notice the cases where you did interview
fitting one metric for that class of
problem till one Mexico better which one
to know well in the iteration and
process for you basically computed a
distance when minimized so for
compressed sensing that is an approach
of using the element norm because where
you exploit the sparsity but I think
yeah I I don't think it performs really
well in the end compared to the
approximate message passing for example
yeah right okay sure
[Applause]
you